para poder empezar esta plática voy a
requerir de la ayuda del público así que
si pudieran ponerse de pie de tres
personas por favor un momento uno dos
tres perfecto con este estado muchas
gracias ahora en lo que se encuentran de
pie esa pregunta va dirigida a todo el
auditorio conocen cuántos libros leemos
en promedio los mexicanos al año
gracias exactamente bueno para todos
aquellos que no conozcan la respuesta la
tienen ahora mismo frente a sus ojos
estas personas representan precisamente
el promedio de libros que leemos en un
año es decir únicamente tres siendo
honestos de acuerdo al inegi las cifras
exactas 3.8 pero tres sonaba un poco más
dramático no ya pueden sentarse muchas
gracias esta pequeña dinámica me hace
recordar algo un tanto similar que me
sucedió meses atrás cuando me encontraba
frente a mi laptop con la mente en
blanco pensando en cuál era la mejor
manera de empezar a escribir un ensayo
para el concurso nacional rol y
percepción de los policías en méxico las
horas pasaban el nivel de estrés subía y
la página de bordado tenía más que el
título curiosamente al igual que hoy con
ustedes
la respuesta la tenía frente a mis ojos
respuesta que ahora mismo traigo mis
manos pero que en ese momento no supe
reconocerle al instante
ese día me bastó con leer unas cuantas
páginas de este libro para obtener la
inspiración que necesitaba y con ello
quedar en los primeros tres lugares del
concurso nacional y es que la lectura
es justamente ese halo como ahora o si
lo traducimos para los módulos aquí
presentes está esa llave maestra que
necesitamos para cuando se nos cierran
las puertas de la creatividad
pero la lectura no únicamente nos sirve
para solucionar problemas de la vida
cotidiana o simples bloqueos creativos
también nos puede servir para dar
respuesta a grandes problemáticas dentro
de nuestra sociedad sobre esto hay una
frase del escritor peruano mario vargas
llosa que en lo personal me agrada mucho
él dice que cuando leemos nos preparamos
para combatir la injusticia yo no podría
estar más de acuerdo con esta frase ya
que nuestro hábito de lectura en méxico
está por los suelos y las injusticias se
encuentran a la orden del día
ahora sí bien no he estado muy de
acuerdo con que tenemos el la frase que
dice que tenemos el gobierno que nos
merecemos si tenemos que ver lo que nos
dicen los datos
es cierto que los resultados que voy a
enseñarles varían dependiendo de quién
elaboren las estadísticas así como de la
metodología utilizada si podemos
encontrar cierta tendencia tomemos como
ejemplo entonces a canadá un país en que
el promedio de libros leídos en un año
va alrededor de 20 libros
qué más podemos encontrar acerca de este
país si hablamos en cuestión de economía
podemos ver que se encuentra en el
décimo lugar como potencia económica a
nivel mundial y el índice de percepción
de corrupción en el lugar número 8 lo
cual lo deja muy bien posicionado
tomemos como ejemplo eeuu un país en el
que se leen en promedio 12 libros al año
si hablamos nuevamente de economía pues
vemos que es el número uno a nivel
mundial y el índice de percepción de
corrupción está un poco más abajo y
canadá en el lugar 16 pero sigue estando
en un muy buen lugar ahora retomamos
nuestro caso méxico por recordemos que
el promedio es 3.8
y economía estamos en el lugar 16 a
nivel mundial lo cual no nos deja tan
mal parados pero tampoco estamos dentro
de los 10 primeros y esto tal vez se
deba a nuestro primer dato ya este
tercero de que el índice de percepción
de corrupción estamos en el lugar 135
la lista de total de países es de 180 o
sea que estamos hasta el fondo casi casi
y es que en nuestro país tal pareciera
que durante años hemos tenido pavor o
incluso fobia diría yo no solo el hábito
sino también el amor y la pasión por
leer mientras que chile y argentina
encabezan las listas como de los países
más lectores nosotros siempre nos
quedamos en los últimos lugares contra
países como colombia
pero por qué será que tenemos este miedo
mi hipótesis que en realidad parte de
una frase de red bradbury en su libro
fahrenheit 451 es que los libros están
para recordarnos lo tontos y estúpidos
que somos
están para hacernos ver que no lo
sabemos todo que allá afuera hay cientos
miles millones de cosas que desconocemos
están incluso para incomodar nos a tal
punto de que de pensar que lo que damos
por cierto ahora mismo puede ser una
mentira
y es que el acto de tomar un libro y
leerlo muchas veces nos asusta porque
nos hace sentir como cuando alguien nos
pide levantarnos de nuestro asiento en
medio de un auditorio repleto de gente
sin tener la menor idea de lo que va a
ocurrir es decir nos atemoriza es cierto
pero nos hace destacar nos pone de pie
ante la injusticia cuando los demás
optan por sentarse y callar pero lo más
importante nos da libertad de conciencia
de pensamiento
desafortunadamente en la actualidad nos
hemos rendido a la comodidad al usuario
al pensamiento promedio
cambiamos 30 minutos de lectura por 3
horas de televisión o de internet y es
que no nos hemos percatado que no
estamos muy lejos de escenarios
distópicos planteados por autores como
orwell o bradbury basta con recordar que
hasta hace poco una historiadora
mexicana simpatizante de cierto partido
político propuso quemar los libros del
escritor vargas llosa luego de que éste
hiciera comentarios acerca del escenario
político en nuestro país una propuesta
que por más nefasta que suene no es
nueva
si hacemos un poco de memoria recordamos
la historia y nos situamos en la época
de la alemania nazi este acto de quemar
libros se llevó a cabo
de cualquier forma y citando nuevamente
a bradbury no hace falta que llamar
libros si el mundo empieza a llenarse de
gente que no lee que no aprende que no
sabe
entender esto es fundamental ya que
mientras unos hacen un llamado a la
opresión y la censura nosotros cada vez
que tomamos un libro y leemos estamos
haciendo un llamado a la libertad de ser
de pensar y de crítica
cuando abandonamos este hábito
sacrificamos nuestra capacidad de
discernir y comenzamos a volverlos
esclavos de todo aquello que nos dicen
y es que la lectura nos ofrece dos cosas
la respuesta a esta pregunta que venimos
formulando en nuestras mentes o por el
contrario de esa pregunta que detona
nuestro interés por conocer su respuesta
de cualquier modo ambos nos llevan a lo
mismo a pensar nos vuelve unos nómadas
del conocimiento en busca de saciar
nuestra sed de sabiduría en lugar de
vivir únicamente como simples entes
consumidores de la opinión y la
desinformación de terceros
todo esto puedo asegurarlo de tal manera
debido a que fue lo que me sucedió
exactamente hace unos años cuando una
maestra me entrego un libro y me hizo
saber que mi mundo y mis ideas no se
reducían simplemente a un aula de clases
si bien creo que todos podemos concordar
en que paulo coelho pudo haber sido su
mejor elección bueno pero eso fue un
parteaguas parteaguas que entonces me
llevaría a buscar nuevas lecturas que
dieran respuesta a cada momento de mi
vida personal y académica pasé así de
ser una persona sin mayor noción de lo
que ocurría a mi alrededor sin ninguna
visión de futuro
mucho menos libertad de pensamiento a
estar en un evento tan importante como
este y frente a un público tan
extraordinario todo esto gracias a la
lectura
y además por si fuera poco la lectura
también nos ofrece conectar con las
personas y en esta conexión tan profunda
que se da con otro ser nos lleva incluso
a encontrar el amor que no es
personalmente en mi caso verdad pero
yo sigo fiel a lo que dice benito taibo
él dice que literatura mata carita yo
sigo muy fiel en eso y esa es mi
filosofía de vida si bien el único
problema es que benito taibo no
especificaba qué tipo de literatura así
que el mejor consejo que puedo dejarles
hoy es nunca usen alguna frase de las
obras del marqués de sade definitiva
todos esos que se están riendo entienden
muy bien el porqué
en fin la diferencia de cierta persona
cuyo nombre no voy a mencionar pero que
seguramente conocen digo en el país es
medianamente popular yo sí puedo
mencionar tres libros que hayan marcado
mi vida
uno de ellos es precisamente el que
traigo desde el inicio de esta plática
es 1984 de george orwell básicamente
trata de una distopía en el que la
sociedad es vigilada y controlada por el
gran hermano esta figura omnipresente
que reúne todas las características de
los grandes gobiernos y líderes
totalitaristas opresión censura
adoctrinamiento ustedes pónganle o bien
si queremos retratar lo de mejor manera
digamos que trata del méxico del siglo
20 o incluso yo me atrevería a decir que
comparte grandes rasgos con nuestro
méxico actual
algo especial mención de este libro
debido a que es uno de los que mayor
impacto ha tenido en mi vida y además
posee una frase poderosísima que en la
novela sirve del lema del partido que
encabeza el gran hermano y esta frase es
la siguiente
guerra es paz libertad es esclavitud
ignorancia es fuerza
he escogido esta frase porque concuerdo
completamente con ella y además resume
toda la idea que quería transmitirles
hoy con esta plática no obstante si me
toma la molestia de darle un pequeño
giro de interpretarlo de manera distinta
así que vamos parte por parte primero
guerra es paz claro si y sólo si esa
guerra es contra nuestra propia
ignorancia contra el pensamiento
impuesto y contra la censura de ideas
segundo libertad es esclavitud
definitivo pero solo si de lo que nos
volvemos esclavos es del hábito de
lectura si nos encadenamos a cada
conocimiento que nos transmite un libro
y por último ignorancia es fuerza sin
duda
pero solo si nos da la fuerza para salir
de la misma y es que lo erróneo lo
erróneo no es ser ignorante todos lo
somos en cierta medida lo erróneo es
sentirnos cómodos en ese estado muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]